[Music]
do you remember the first computer you
ever used or the TV you once watch
cartoons on it's easy to take modern
technology for granted but if you
compare it to the room size computers of
the 1960's you'll notice how quickly
things have changed or rather how much
they've shrunk as technology advances
the amount of data we need to store and
manipulate is increasing and the size of
devices is decreasing so much that
conventional techniques of data storage
won't be good enough for long most
modern technology is electronic it uses
a property of electrons called charge to
encode information
one example is computer memory often
called RAM which is where computers keep
information they're working with for
several seconds or minutes RAM contains
billions of tiny plates called
capacitors that hold electrons to store
information computers send a current of
electrons into the capacitors some of
these electrons collect on the plates if
the number of electrons on a capacitor
is above a threshold the computer
assigns it a value of 1 otherwise it's a
zero unique patterns of zeros and ones
encode information like letters numbers
and images as chips get smaller so do
capacitors and we are faced with a
problem of charge leakage electrons
constantly slip away from the plates
when the electron count falls below the
threshold the stored data is lost to
avoid this computers have to recharge
their capacitors several times per
second which requires more and more
power as chips shrink
fortunately an emerging technology
called spintronics could solve this
problem spent Ronix uses spin another
property of electrons to encode data the
spin of an electron is either up or down
it is helpful to think of spin up
electrons as little magnets with their
north poles pointing up and spend down
electrons with downwards pointing north
poles data is stored based on the spin
states of electrons that are already
present this means that there is no
problem of leakage with spintronics once
information is stored it stays there
until we want to change it the spin
states of electrons change if we
actively influence them by exposing them
to magnetic fields to take advantage of
this scientists developed magneto
resistive RAM which replaces capacitors
with tunneling magnetoresistance
structures TMR structures are made up of
an insulator sandwiched between two
ferromagnetic materials an insulator is
a material with very high resistivity
this means that electrons are very
unlikely to move through it a Ferro
magnet is a material in which the spins
tend to align along the same direction
the lower ferromagnetic layer is fixed
its electrons are forced to have the
same spin as each other by an adjacent
strong magnet the upper ferromagnetic
layer is free its electrons change their
spins in response to external magnetic
fields or through a phenomenon called
spin transfer torque which is where
electrons change their spins to match
the spins of nearby flowing electrons
when the spins of the ferromagnetic
layers are parallel the structure stores
a 1 opposite spins represent a 0 to read
the data and determine whether it's a 0
or a 1 the computer sends a tiny current
through the TMR structure if the spins
of the top and bottom layers are
parallel electrons can tunnel through
the insulator tunneling is a process
that is similar to a basketball moving
through a solid wall it's normally very
unlikely but parallel spins make it
possible
if the spins are opposite almost no
electrons tunnel through by seeing how
much current reaches the other side of
ughter can tell whether the structure is
holding a 1 or 0 to write data we send
larger current up or down the structure
sending electrons up the structure from
the fixed layer to the free layer
switches the value from a 0 to 1 because
it's been transferred torque the flowing
electrons adopt the fixed layer spin as
they move through it the electrons in
the free layer then flipped to match the
spins of the flowing electrons
since the free layer responds to changes
in external magnetic fields which are
generated by both computers and living
organisms TMR structures have numerous
applications beyond computers when a
neuron in your brain fires your
heartbeats or a white blood cell attacks
a virus tiny magnetic fields are created
a spintronic sensor chip could detect
the smallest deviations from your normal
magnetic fields detecting anything from
bacterial infections to brain tumors
because magnetic fields are not altered
by the structures they move through it
could even do this from outside the body
and because electron spin changes our
near-instant spintronics technology
could do so quickly ultimately
spintronics technology holds promise in
countless areas from computer memory to
medicine and beyond
[Music]